Thankfully, Naruto took after his parents
and had a caring teacher in Iruka-Sensei
who was a positive role model for the
young shinobi. Thanks to those factors,
Naruto grew up into the person we know and
love - embodying the values of friendship
and teamwork. It also helped that he’s the
reincarnation of a really nice guy. [show Asura]
But what if Naruto hadn’t had that
great influence in his life? After all,
Iruka’s own parents were killed
by the Nine-Tailed Fox that lives
inside of Naruto - he had every reason to despise
Naruto just like everyone else in the village,
leading Naruto to go down a very dark
path similar to Sasuke. So, how would the
Naruto world look different if our hero became
a villain? What if Naruto joined the Akatsuki?
Well, first off, we have a pretty good idea
of what happens when a kid with the power of
a tailed beast is completely mal-adjusted
and has a horrible upbringing. Just take
a look at Gaara. When we first meet Gaara,
he is contrasted with Naruto because their
stories are so similar. Both of them are
Jinchuriki - the term for someone with a
tailed beast sealed inside them. Both of them
had lonely and painful childhoods. However,
Gaara lacked a relationship like
Naruto had with Iruka Sensei.
Instead, Gaara had a relationship with his
uncle Yashamaru. The two were very close,
but Yashamaru was ordered by Gaara’s own father
to assassinate him. After being betrayed by the
only person he loved, Gaara fell deeper into
darkness, hatred, and violence. Can’t really
blame him - I think I’d do the same if my
own uncle tried to assassinate me. However,
there’s one major difference: Gaara was still used
as a pawn and weapon by the Hidden Sand Village.
Naruto’s powers, however, were restricted
at all costs by the Hidden Leaf Village.
The Nine-Tailed Beast, Kurama, was simply too
powerful to contain. After all, as everyone knows,
the more tails you have, the stronger you are.
Instead of being able to use these powers, Naruto
tapping into the beast’s chakra risked unleashing
the Nine Tailed Fox to attack Konoha again.
This time, when Orochimaru and the Sand Village
attack the Hidden Leaf during the Chunin Exams,
things would play out extremely differently.
In Naruto as we know it, the Sand Village send
their greatest weapon, Gaara, to attack the
Hidden Leaf in order to improve their own
economic conditions. I mean, they could have
just instituted a higher capital gains tax,
but go off, I guess. Thankfully, Naruto
was there to go head to head with Gaara,
eventually causing the fellow
Jinchuriki to have a change of heart.
In this timeline, though, Naruto won’t influence
Gaara. It will be the other way around. The
Leaf Jonin such as Kakashi and Might Guy will
ultimately be able to stave off Gaara’s attack,
even though he has the power of Shukaku on
his side. This is especially true if Jiraiya,
one of the legendary Sannin, gets
involved in the fight as well. After all,
the natural weakness of sand is toads…obviously.
However, Naruto will see how powerful Gaara
is when he utilizes the strength of the beast
within him. He’ll see how feared he
is by his own village and siblings.
He’ll see how the Sand Village will bend to
his will in order to avoid angering Gaara.
Knowing that he can’t be loved by the citizens
of Konoha, Naruto might take another path:
being feared. He’ll become more aggressive
toward his fellow classmates and villagers
and won’t fear tapping more recklessly into
Kurama’s chakra to enhance his own strength.
The only danger is Kurama convincing Naruto to
undo the seal and unleashing the beast - However,
I’m going to say he won’t give in
to Kurama’s temptation to release
him because Naruto will want to
control that power for himself.
In our new timeline, instead of staying in
the Hidden Leaf Village as a member of Team 7,
Naruto will be pushed away. After being
rejected by the citizens of the village,
he’ll abandon his home and run away. In
an inversion of the Sasuke rescue arc,
we can still see these two fated
rivals compete against one another.
Instead of eyeing Sasuke for his replacement body,
this time Orochimaru could seek out Naruto - yes,
Sasuke has the sharingan, but it’s clear
that Orochimaru would be interested in
the immense powers of Kurama. So this
time, the Konoha shinobi would try to
retrieve Naruto from the Sound Four leading to
a familiar showdown between Naruto and Sasuke.
However, there are two differences this time.
Firstly, Sasuke would be missing his curse
mark - and on top of that Naruto would be way more
willing to tap into Kurama’s chakra. Therefore,
Naruto would absolutely stomp
Sasuke in their battle this time.
However, just like Sasuke, Naruto would soon
realize he’s being used by Orochimaru and would
abandon his side in order to achieve his own
goals. It just so happens, too, that there’s an
organization that’s specifically on the lookout
for Jinchuriki: The Akatsuki. And Naruto would
already be somewhat aware of this organization,
too. First Orochimaru was temporarily aligned with
the group and more importantly, he had encountered
Itachi and Kisame previously. Since Naruto’s
biggest rival in Konoha was Sasuke, it makes sense
that Naruto may join up with Itachi - after all,
the enemy of your enemy is your friend.
The Akatsuki would allow him to enact his
revenge against the Hidden Leaf Village who had
treated him poorly throughout his childhood.
The Akatsuki was originally formed to promote
peace in the shinobi world: and in a twisted way,
that’s still its ultimate goal when we meet the
Akatsuki in the story. It’s just that they’re
like…super bad at it, considering their whole
recruitment process is based on how evil the
candidates are. They’re working as mercenaries
for various villages in order to gain wealth,
but they’re also in the business
of collecting Tailed Beasts. Why?
Well, that’s because the Tailed Beasts
are the ultimate weapons in the Naruto
world - they’re the equivalent to weapons of
mass destruction - unleashing a tailed beast
on a village might as well be like launching
a nuclear warhead. The leader of the Akatsuki,
Nagato, wants to obtain each of the
Tailed Beasts so that he can conquer
all of the world’s villages and stop them from
engaging in wars with one another by force.
In Naruto Shippuden, we see the Akatsuki
come into focus as the main antagonists of
the series. They target the Jinchuriki within
each of the villages in order to steal their
tailed beast chakra. For example, Deidara captures
Gaara, and the Akatsuki steal his tailed beast,
killing the newly crowned Kazekage. Thankfully
Grandma Chiyo was able to sacrifice her life
to resurrect him, but it was a close
call (with a hint of Deus ex Machina).
However, in this timeline, Gaara likely wouldn’t
have gone down so easily. Since Naruto never talk
no jutsu’d him after the Chunin Exams, Gaara
would still be filled with violence and malice,
giving him more of an advantage against
Deidara. During their battle in the real series,
Gaara has to use up a lot of his sand and
chakra in order to save the village from
one of Deidara’s massive explosions. But in this
timeline, he’d have no reason to care about saving
the villagers and would be able to dedicate his
full strength to fighting the explosive clay user.
But luckily, the Akatsuki would have a
trick up their sleeve: their new member,
Naruto Uzumaki. The only question is: when Naruto
knocked on the Akatsuki’s door looking to join,
why wouldn’t their leader, Nagato, simply take
his tailed beast right then and there? Well, first
off, there is the fact that Naruto is Nagato’s
distant cousin and a fellow member of the Uzumaki
clan. But we have a feeling that Nagato isn’t the
type to get too sentimental about family ties.
More important is the fact that Naruto
harnesses the power of the Nine-Tails. Remember:
the more tails a beast has, the more powerful
it is, which means Naruto has more chakra
potential than any of the other Jinchuriki. If
Naruto was willing to join the organization,
he’s practically tailor made for hunting down
the remaining Jinchuriki. The only question is:
would Naruto realize the natural end point,
which was that after the rest of the Tailed
Beasts were captured, they would simply
do the same to him? Well, as we all know,
Naruto is…not the smartest. Though, there’s
also an argument to be made that if he was
working with the Akatsuki anyway, they
could still use his beast as a weapon
of mass destruction without having to strip it
from Naruto. Nagato’s plan could still work. Of
course, we have to consider Tobi’s plan,
too…but we’ll save that for a bit later.
Therefore, where Deidara would likely
fail against a still evil Gaara, Naruto
would succeed. The only question is: would
they still strip Gaara of his tailed beast,
or would the organization recruit Gaara as
well in this timeline. Just like Naruto,
Gaara would want revenge against his village
and would thrive in an organization like the
Akatsuki that would allow him to channel his
violent impulses into mercenary missions.
With Gaara and Naruto as the newest team
of the Akatsuki, taking out the remaining
Jinchuriki would be a piece of cake.
Most of them were easily obtained by
the Akatsuki as they existed - therefore, with
the strength of two Jinchuriki on their side,
they’d have no problem collecting all of
the tailed beasts. Well…all of the tailed
beasts except one, that is: what they
wouldn’t have considered is Killer B.
Killer B, the right-hand man to the Raikage, is
known as a Perfect Jinchuriki. Instead of being
at odds with the power inside of him, he has an
actual relationship with the Eight-Tailed Beast,
Gyuki. Instead of vying for power and control
with the monster, the two can work in sync to
become even stronger. He can even undergo
a massive tailed-beast transformation. It’s
unknown whether the tailed-beast chakra
has any effect on his rap skills, though.
Even with such great control of Gyuki,
though, it’s unlikely that he could contend
with the all of the members of this Akatsuki
- Even without complete control of Kurama,
Naruto’s chakra is overwhelming and he’d
have back up from the likes of Gaara,
Itachi, Pain, and other absolute power houses.
So, with Naruto as an Akatsuki member, this
criminal organization would achieve their goal
of capturing every tailed beast. However, Nagato
didn’t account for a traitor in his midst. Tobi,
AKA Obito Uchiha as well as Black
Zetsu have been manipulating things
behind the scenes for ages, even
before the Akatsuki were formed.
While Nagato may have been content with Gaara
and Naruto utilizing their tailed beasts as
Jinchuriki, this wouldn’t work for Tobi’s
plan. His goal was to reunite all of the
Nine Tailed Beasts into their original
form: the immensely powerful Ten-Tails.
Though it would be a true battle, Tobi and the
Zetsus would likely be able to use deception
to catch Gaara or Naruto individually and
off guard in order to capture their beasts.
With these, Tobi would be
able to resurrect Madara,
but in turn Kaguya Otsutsuki would also be
summoned. Whereas in the original series,
Naruto and Sasuke were able to combine their
powers in order to barely overcome this threat
to the planet Sasuke would be the last line of
defense against the Infinite Tsukuyomi and the
harvesting of all humans into a chakra
fruit for the Otsutsuki’s enjoyment.
So what if Naruto joined the Akatsuki?
Well - it wouldn’t be good: in fact, Naruto
joining the Akatsuki would spell the destruction
of the entire shinobi world. Remember to thank a
teacher today, because without Iruka-Sensei
it would have been the end of the world!